ich habe den günstigsten 992 GT3
Deutschlands gekauft das Problem an der
Sache es ist ein Unfallwagen mit
unheimlich vielen Schäden von denen wir
nicht mal wissen ob wir sie überhaupt
jemals repariert bekommen genau diese
Frage und viele weitere wollen wir in
Folge 3 des Wiederaufbaus meines 992 GT3
klären ich wünsche euch viel Spaß ihr
könnt es euch nicht vorstellen ich bin
so unglaublich happy dass es weiter geht
ich bin auf dem Weg zum Karosseriebauer
was bedeutet wir können heute endlich
mit den Karosseriearbeiten anfangen
Karre wieder aufbauen und in diesem
Moment komme ich an bei
teegartenkarosserie ich kann es nicht
fassen außerdem bin ich mega pumpt weil
ich das erste Mal Karosseriearbeiten
mache und mit Sicherheit eine Menge
lernen kann genau deswegen verlieren wir
keine Zeit also ist schon völlig
verrückt vor zwei Wochen war das Auto
ganz bzw komplett zusammengebaut und
jetzt liegt es komplett in Einzelteilen
und das Auto sieht mehr nach einem
unfallle aus als vorher aber wir sind
viele viele Schritte näher daran die
Karre wieder auf die Straße zu bekommen
was für ein Traum der Wiederaufbau geht
genau jetzt los so als erstes bauen wir
vorne ab was noch da ist alle Kabel
Kabelbaum Homelink Trafo irgendwelche
Halterungen für die Klimaanlage kühler
und so weiter einfach alles
weg schaut mal hier das ist die
Messeinheit mit der wir die Karre jetzt
noch mal komplett durchmessen können
wurd zwar schon bei Porsche gemacht aber
das ist jetzt noch mal ein geileres
System bei dem wir richtig einmal
komplett auf die Punkte drauf kommen und
nicht um irgendwelche Punkte drum rum
messen müssen dann schauen wir mal wie
das funktioniert und hier steht die
Karre drauf dann weiß das Gerät quasi wo
das ist wo das Auto ist wo es selber ist
wird das jetzt noch mal kalibriert
wahrscheinlich oder so dann gibt diesen
Nullpunkt h erstmal die messchiine dann
hast du den messchnitten der muss
erstmal wissen wo er ist dann wird er
jetzt angemacht dann connecten die sich
und dann einmal in XY Z Richtung einmal
alles machen zeig das an hier jetzt
müssen wir hinten auf den
null
jetzt drücken wir den einmal
ab akustisches Signal krass er macht
immer den Ton wenn er checkt dass er
richtig ist mal gibt sogar Applaus
okay wie man unschwer erkennen kann
begeistere ich mich für alles was mit
Innovation und Erfindergeist zu tun hat
völlig egal ob von komplexen
Karosseriearbeiten der porscheereihe
oder den einfachen Dingen im Leben und
am besten dann wenn man das Gefühl hat
es war so simpel wie genial und es liegt
auf der Hand ich hätte selber drauf
kommen können genau diesen Gedanken
hatte ich als das erstmal er abprobiert
hab ich meine ihr kennt das System
Deckel auf Pot hochziehen normales
Leitungswasser trinken und das Gefühl
haben irgendwas mit Geschmack zu trinken
irendein Softgetränk was auch immer von
Ananas über Cola und vielen
weiteren was soll ich sagen es
funktioniert und ich meine allen von
euch ist klar in wenigen Tagen ist
Weihnachten und wieder einmal steht der
Tag vor der Tür an dem man irgendwelche
unnötigen Geschenke von Freunden und
Verwandten bekommt und auch selber
verschenkt und damit euch das nicht
passiert könnt ihr einfach auf den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
klicken und die weihnachtlichen Deals
von airab abchecken und damit auf jeden
Fall für egal wen Freunde Familie euren
Lieblingskollegen das richtige Geschenk
machen vielen Dank an a abfüs
unterstützen dieser Videoreihe und euch
viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video klickt
auf den Link und checkt es aus im
weiteren Verlauf des vermessens konnten
wir anhand von unheimlich vielen Punkten
an der Karosserie auf Millimeter genaue
Weise bestimmen dass der Rahmen des
Fahrzeugs nicht krumm ist diese
Information gepaart mit der
Expertenmeinung von tegartenkarosserie
alleine entscheidet darüber dass wir den
Wagen tatsächlich reparieren können und
genau damit soll es losgehen also
oropacks rein jetzt h ich nichts mehr
Brille auf jetzt können wir damit
anfangen die vorhandenen ja sieht sehr
gut aus damit anfangen die
vorhanden die vorhandenen Klebestellen
abzumachen damit wir dann den ganzen
Vorderwagen rausprennen können liebe
[Musik]
Grüße
ne noch
glückaber gerade gesagt dafür ist halt
diese Decke da ne s schutzdecken sind
auch
[Musik]
feuerfest so jetzt haben wir das grob
rausgeschnitten dass wir schön nachher
an die Fließen rankommen und dann kann
man nachher mit der Presse schön
hingehen und schön die Nieten
rausstanzen das man schön weitseitig
Zugang hat schön und gut aber die
Karosserie ist ja nicht der einzige
Schaden am Auto das hier ist der
Fahrersitz des Wagens die Sitze eh ein
absolutes Highlight für mich komplett
aus Carbon mega leicht aber beim
Aufprall eben auch kaputt gegangen hier
in der Seite hat sich der Airbag
geöffnet und das soll er im Zweifelsfall
beim nächsten Aufprall auch tun deswegen
muss sich ein sehr erfahrener
porscheattler darum kümmern da muss die
Nadel und Fadenstärke passen damit
dieses Ding eben wieder aufgeht und
damit es nicht so aussieht als wäre
dieser Sitz jemals kaputt bzw offen
gesehen den Sitz neukauft ist keine
Option denn so ein einzelner Sitz
Fahrerseite 992 GT3 kostet ca 1000 € in
absoluter Feinarbeit hat Fabian von
exclusive car interior in kürzester Zeit
mein carbonschalensitz mit originalleder
und näten wiederhergerichtet dafür
musste der gesamte Sitz auseinander
genommen und komplett neu gesattelt
werden was für
Trum vielen Dank ihr müsst euch
vorstellen wäre dieser Mann nicht
gewesen und hätte das mit original
Porsche Leder original Porsche alle
perfekt so in kürzester Zeit gemacht
wäre ich allerfühestens im Januar mit
dem Auto wieder auf der Straße
gewesen Tag Nummer 2 bei meinen Freunden
von teegartenkarosserie gestern konnten
wir die Wanne schon grob Heraustrennen
um uns einfacheren Zugang zu verschaffen
jetzt heißt es in mühevoller Kleinarbeit
die letzten Überreste zu damit gar nicht
mehr Bohen nein damit damit komplett
ohne ich habe gesehen best auch 99
g3gebaut der so 20 Boher verkackt ja das
wenig ja ja du setzt die einmal schön an
wichtig ist dass du dass du nicht
verkannt ist und dass das schön mittig
ist weil das ist quasi auch die Prägung
die Vorgabe für unser
Neuteil also da schon richtig Druck
drauf ne da pressen paar Tonnen fährst
wieder
zurück hast du ein sauberes Loch da drin
ja hier hast du die alte nietete ne den
Auswurf und dann geht's
weiter
wir haben es ja schon gehört also es
gibt eine niet an die wir mit der Presse
nicht vernünftig dran kommen ohne den
Bügel zu wechseln deswegen nehmen wir
die jetzt als testniete um zu zeigen wie
scheiße das mit dem Bohen ist als erstes
billiger Bohrer plus man darf auf keinen
Fall verkacken dieses Loch muss am Ende
h genau 6,6 mm sein kein millmet mehr
kein Millimeter weniger das bedeutet mit
Abrutschen bisschen links und rechts
bewegen um das Ding freiubekommen ist
nicht also das hier muss genau sitzen
und genau deswegen übernehme ich die
Arbeit
hier geht vielleicht habe ich doch den
guten Bohrer
bekommen geht aber ist deutlich
beschissener als jetzt siehst halt was
ich meine mit dem mit dem mit dem
Zeitunterschied
ne so Nieten alle rausgedrückt
rausgebohrt es gilt es hier die ganzen
Schweiß noch aufzumachen ganz wichtig
hat an mir gerade erzählt gibt eine
Sache die nennt Kontaktkorrosion
bedeutet wir dürfen zwischen dem Stahl
und dem Alu die Werkzeuge nicht hin und
her benutzen weil wir die Späne vom
Stahl z.B nicht in dem Alu mit drin
haben wollen weil sonst das Alu das ja
eigentlich nicht korrodiert durch die
stahlspäne anfangen kann verö zu werden
oder irgendwie scheiße zu werden
deswegen neues Band auf dem
Bandschleifer und bei Alu Mundschutz
augenschutznschutz weil der Staub die
sperne sind richtig scheiße machen wir
das mal
weg was mich riesig gefreut hat ist dass
ich unter professioneller Anleitung von
Teegarten einen großen Teil der Arbeiten
selber durchführen konnte und genau das
ist es nämlich was diese ganzen Serien
für mich ausmachen ich kann neue bisher
unbekannte Jobs reinschnuppern und
einfach mal ein Gefühl bekommen sobald
es aber ernst wird ist Andy natürlich
nicht weit und ich werde wieder zum
Mensch gewordenen F um den alten Kleber
aufzulösen damit Andy die verbleiibende
Teile der alten kofferraumwande
raustrennen
und wo wir gerade schon mal bei Profis
sind ihr könnt es euch schon denken ich
zieh mir Mundschutz Brille und oropx an
und ma mich wieder an die
[Musik]
schleif wiee bist hieril ich habe noch
nicht hier bin seit gestern und noch
paar
Tage ja wie ein
aut
[Musik]
so jetzt auf Sponti glücklicherweise bei
Teegarten gehen die Profis ein und aus
bedeutet jetzt ist ein bollendoktor da
der probiert uns hinten links am
Kotflügel war der Kotflügel ja so leicht
eingedellt und best case kriegen wir den
raus ohne das Le neu lackieren zu müssen
genau das versuchen wir jetzt guck mal
hier professionelles
Licht krank
ja der macht aber schwer macht die ganze
hoch und
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
runter schon so viel besser krank
innerhalb von 2 Minuten also wirklich
Profis du what Profis du richtig krass
TÜ vielen vielen Dank krass richtig
[Musik]
krass W hinten gerade die Beule
rausgemacht wurde ist Andy hier schon
fleißig am vermessen den letzten im
letzten Tag also gestern und heute hier
alles abgemacht bum bum bum
abgeschliffen das wisst ihr ja alles
hier ist ein neues Teil dafür haben wir
einmal die Karre komplett neu
eingemessen weil die Schiene wieder
zentriert werden muss bzw eingemessen
werden muss jetzt hier oben das Teil
können wir anfangen hier Löcher zu
bohren und dieses obere Teil quasi schon
mal ja fertig für die Installation
machen das übelst geil und dafür hier
diese kranke Konstruktion von hier unten
ist der Messarm Boom hier hoch zack zack
da rein es gibt Toleranzen aber man will
natürlich alles auf 00 0 mm Toleranz das
ist dann einfach Sache für ein Profi und
bin ich mega happy das obwohl es nicht
sein müsste hier alles bis auf den
letzten Millimeter austariert wird damit
die Karre einfach wieder genauso perfekt
D steht wie sie aus dem Werk kommt bzw
noch
[Musik]
besser sind am born and hat über viel
hin und her und hin und her alles
perfekt ausgerichtet damit es wieder
perfekt wird das bedeutet wir können
jetzt die Löcher bohren die dann genau
an der richtigen Position sind um
nächste Woche dieses Blech fertig zu
machen wenn der gesamt untere Teil da
ist also hieß es neue Löcher ins neue
Teil Bohen um schon mal die finale
Position des Teils fixieren zu können
das Problem ab diesem Zeitpunkt stand
die Arbeit für uns erstmal still und das
auf unbestimmte Zeit die schon mehrfach
angesprochene kofferraumwande ist nicht
lieferbar und zu unserem leitwesen soll
das nicht unser einziges Problem bleiben
wenn ihr mich also auf diesem ungeahnt
steinigen Weg begleiten woll und
erfahren möchtet wie es mit dem
Wiederaufbau weitergeht vergesst nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren und freut Euch
auf weitere
folgen